a band of lost Vikings head south for
some good pillaging converts to Islam
and teaches us all we need to know about
the secrets of the rooms huh you're that
right today it's all the rooms you can
handle first learn what rooms are and
how the Norse used them then watch the
endless not to explore the history of
the word rune and some surprising ways
runes are still relevant to our own
tongue it's a double dose of runic
content onto our story Spain the early
Middle Ages the right kind of time and
place for the Muslim conquest to drive
out the ruling Goths and then for the
new ruler to turn around and declare
Spain his own emirate but it's also the
right kind of time in place for some
marauding Vikings here they come sailing
down the coast around 840 and what
Vikings do give me some words they they
raid they pillage they they sack yes the
Norseman sacked Lisbon and then sailed
up to Sevilla in 844 they attacked they
stirred up panic and then they held out
for weeks waiting for the ransom Gold
when it did arrive surprise it wasn't
gold it was a Muslim army ready to crush
the Vikings and burn their ships try
again wait some decades reinvade Seville
and get slaughtered by more Andalusian
forces now only ovens Ravens know what
happens next but the story goes that a
small band of Vikings escaped wandered
around and settled in southern Spain
were they converted to Islam and became
the region's first cheesemakers the
Vikings themselves aren't the ones
telling us this tale no we get tales of
Viking raids from their victims who
wrote in bookish scripts like Arabic and
Latin in Arabic they didn't even know
what to call them so Vikings were majus
Magi Zoroastrians the Maja's weren't
just pillaging Spain they hit England
and Scotland 50 years earlier they
stormed Normandy in Paris they sacked
Ligurian Pisa found it Bruce in the east
so they're even to think for Russia and
Ukraine
they threatened Constantinople were
hired to guard Constantinople and let
this graffiti in the Ayasofya they even
took a Greek holiday to etch runes into
the purest lion near Athens
now hold your tears but the lost vikings
makers might just be a legend based on
an interpretation based on an arabic
text but that brings up a bigger
linguistic question why do we run to
Arabic and Latin for a Viking history
did the Norse not know how to write meet
the runes this is the elder futhark it's
the oldest form of the runes and it
works like a full-on alphabet it's not
the ABCs though it's a futhark
ooh are these straight line letters
perfect for wood and stone are hundreds
of years older than the Vikings though
it's hard to say where they come from
and they look italic but what kind of
italic Latin some other old italic
alphabet but they evolved too right
early Germanic languages like proto
Norse artifacts in the Elder Futhark are
rare
mostly Scandinavian and all short often
very short this comb is our oldest says
hottia that doesn't mean hair that would
be funny but it's probably a personal
name personal names time after time
these things say this is my name and I
made this like on these Danish golden
horns from the 5th century I Kilowog a
speech hole T as made this horn but
these rooms weren't all about passing
information runes offered protection
magic words like T was the god 2 and
Tuesday lucasz for garlic and all over
the place
all hail o and in this ale you can see
how the writing direction wasn't even
always left to right so runes had power
or in the words of this room stone
master of runes I hide here runes of
power forever plagued by evil deeds and
doomed to insidious death whoever breaks
this I like it those still aren't Viking
runes
these are Viking runes the futhark took
this shape just a bit before the sacking
and pillaging at the beginning of our
story this is called the younger futhark
and it was a big change spot the
difference at a time when Latin was busy
adding letters the Norse were actually
going backwards in a way
cutting letters out they got rid of the
and guy even though they were still
pronouncing them now but and cut had to
do double duty this happened with a
number of letters consonants and vowels
by the way these magical runes they all
have fancy dramatic names the younger
futhark was short on letters but not on
inscriptions today we only have hundreds
of inscriptions in the elder futhark
compared to thousands upon thousands in
the younger futhark mostly rune stones
honoring dead men the language of these
imposing stones is Old Norse and it's
already very different from that proton
or from earlier younger futhark rune
stones give us a second look at those
ominous seafaring Raiders so despised
and feared by the book and ink crowd
Guney raised this stone in memory of
Rodney his good son he died on the
western route bragging voltar had the
runes carved he was in Greece he was
commander of the retinue Unga raised
this stone in memory of all a fish he
plowed his Stern to the east and met his
end in Italy they fostered had this
stone raised up in memory of Goethe
lumber his brother he died in the
abbasid caliphate
may God help his spirit then the end of
the Viking Age pagan Scandinavia was
Christianized but were they done with
runes not right away when King Harald
Bluetooth told the world how he
converted the Danes he used a rune stone
Sweden has the greatest concentration of
rune stones and many of them are late
and explicitly Christian but then watch
out there still Thor's hammer the Latin
alphabet took over in the 1100 s when
the Norse fully joined the book in ink
club and wrote down their Eddas and
sagas but interest in the runes lingered
they made a medieval come back in codex
runic is for writing Nordic laws they
even survived in a pocket of Sweden as
the Dalek Carleen runes into the 1800s
the old wounds were terse they were
short on words but rich with names they
meant kinship protection and remembrance
to a people that didn't see writing as
the mellifluous prose of Arabic and
Latin well at least to the ones it
didn't convert to a book any culture and
start making cheese but the Norse
weren't the only room
masters around in the first millennium
can watch the endless not to explore the
etymological twists and turns taken by
runes and the word rune itself in the
history of English stick around and
subscribe for language